das ist einfach so viel härter als ich
gedacht hatte hi ich bin Marie ich stehe
total auf Selbstversorgung und mein
größter Traum überhaupt ist es einen
eigenen kleinen Hof zu haben und nachdem
ich circa vier Jahre auf der Suche war
habe ich dann einen passenden Hof
gefunden gekauft und im Juli können wir
endlich endlich einziehen
genauso habe ich mich bis vor kurzem
noch gefühlt wenn ich an den Umzug
gedacht habe aber mittlerweile sieht das
etwas anders aus
[Musik]
ich habe mich bis vor kurzem so auf den
neuen Hof gefreut dass ich obwohl der
Umzug noch Monate weit weg ist schon
über 15 Umzugskartons eingepackt habe
[Musik]
bisher gärtnere ich auf dem Grundstücken
von anderen Leuten die ich netterweise
nutzen darf und auch wenn das nicht mein
eigener Garten ist habe ich doch in den
letzten Jahren eine ziemlich tiefe
Verbindung aufgebaut zu diesem Stückchen
Land auf dem ich unser Gemüse selber
angebaut habe unser Obst geerntet und
unsere Tiere gehalten habe
und die Vorfreude ist auch nicht weg
aber je näher der Umzug rückt desto mehr
schwankt es zwischen absoluter Euphorie
und so einer tiefen Wehmut zum Beispiel
vorgestern war wieder so eine Aktion
echt
[Musik]
wir haben eine allererste Sache für
unseren neuen Hof gekauft und da fahren
wir jetzt mal hin da ist
[Musik]
das da ist unser erstes eigenes Holz für
den Kamin auf dem Hof und mein Freund
hat hier immer ganz viel Holz
so wie der Vogel scheißt so der Stamm
aufreißt so von oben nach unten
[Musik]
ich habe ziemlich doll Respekt vor Äxten
und vor ja Echsen
und ja bis jetzt mein erstes Mal direkt
mit dem riesenspalthammer
zeigen
[Musik]
ich gehe ein bisschen mit der Kamera
reden ich habe mir gerade mit der Axt so
was im Fuß gehabt
und
jetzt irgendwie ganz schön erschrocken
und irgendwie auch so frustriert weil
ich immer bei diesen Sachen wo man
Holzspalten muss oder
oder Werkzeuge wie eine Axt oder ein
Ball verwendet
passiert mir immer die dümmsten Sachen
und ich habe das Gefühl ich bin der
größte Torwart schon ich würde so gerne
diese Sachen können aber irgendwie
irgendwie klappt es nicht oder ich weiß
es total albern ist deswegen zu weinen
ist ganze Thema Umzug macht mich
irgendwie so emotional
weil ich
so lange darauf hingefiebert habe und
sie jetzt mit jedem Tag näher rückt dass
wir endlich auf den Hof ziehen können
und ich freue mich so auf den Hof und es
ist so schön da aber ich kann mir das
irgendwie noch gar nicht vorstellen wie
das dann wird da zu sein das ist
überhaupt nicht real
in die Welt auf jeden Fall die Stadt wo
wir jetzt tun ganz schön vermissen weil
es ist eine ganz tolle Stadt und da
wurden viele von meinen Freunden da ist
auch meine Firma hier wächst sauer
immerhin ist mein Lieblingsbild gerade
mein Freund und ich ziehen übrigens auch
ähm zusammen zum ersten Mal ähm wenn wir
auf den Hof ziehen das wird also auch
komplett neu für uns wir hatten mein
Freund übrigens noch in keinem meiner
Videos gesehen außer vielleicht mal
seine Hände
wir sind jetzt anderthalb Jahre zusammen
und ich habe ihn ganz gut geheim
gehalten mal gucken wie das wird wenn
wir auf den Hof ziehen ob ich dann
irgendwann entscheide dass ich ihm
zeigen möchte das muss er natürlich dann
auch entscheiden das ist ein ganz ganz
toller kannst du mal nicht mal selber
nicht so ganz glauben da machst du
einfach nur mit der benutzt sein die
kleine Axel Spalter mal weil wir ein
Stumpf ist wie ein Spalt gemacht
wenn mir so viele Sachen durch den Kopf
gehen oder ich Sachen fühle die ich
eigentlich gar nicht fühlen will dann
stellt sich mich normalerweise ganz tief
in die Arbeit damit ich ja keine Zeit
habe darüber nachzudenken kann sein dass
das nicht das Gesündeste ist was man
machen kann aber es gibt ein Projekt das
mir gerade so viel Freude bereitet und
dass mich in den letzten Monaten immer
wieder ist mein düsteren Gedanken
gerissen hat
das Eva meine Kamera Frau ich habe euch
ja schon erzählt dass wir schon sehr
lange an unserem Garten Shop arbeiten
und jetzt steht die endspurphase an Eva
und ich machen heute die ganzen
Produktfotos und an dem Tag an dem
dieses Video hier online geht geht auch
unser gartenshop Online das heißt ihr
könnt jetzt vorbei schauen und gucken ob
wir was schönes findet für euch und
euren Garten
richtig Spaß wird einfach so toll
aussieht
schaut mal
ist nicht ein unfassbar schönes Foto es
ist einfach richtig gut so einen
Vollprofi wie Eva dabei zu haben weil
ich selber gar nicht so viel Peilung von
Fotografie habe und irgendwann war das
Licht dann so schön man sieht das hier
auf den Aufnahmen gar nicht weil ich die
mit dem Handy gemacht habe und dass das
niemals so einfängt wie eine Kamera und
wir waren alle beide so euphorisch
deswegen ganz schnell alle Werkzeuge die
wir haben noch mal an dieser Stelle
fotografiert haben und wir haben sogar
weil das Licht so schön war eine
löwenzahnpflanze aus einem anderen Beet
ausgegraben und hier wieder eingepflanzt
einfach nur damit wir noch mal neue
Fotos von dem Wurzel Stecher machen
konnten und hier ist das Endergebnis
hier sind ein paar von den Fotos die wir
gemacht haben ihr könnt gerne mal
Feedback da lassen wie ihr die findet
und dann ging es weiter mit einer völlig
verrückten Aktion
oh mein Gott die Idee ist nämlich dass
wenn ihr mein Buch in unserem Shop
bestellt dass ihr dann die signierte
Ausgabe bekommt und die Koks an der
Sache ist dass ich nur fünf Stunden Zeit
habe bis ich weiter muss zu einem
anderen Termin in einer anderen Stadt
und ja mal gucken ob wir das schaffen
[Musik]
so wir haben das geschafft wir haben das
geschafft und jetzt haben wir noch 40
Minuten für den ganzen Rest 50 Minuten
kriegen wir das hin
zum Glück waren Lara und Manuel aus dem
Wurzeln haben wir geholfen einer hat
immer das Buch hingelegt ich habe
unterschrieben und dann hat der andere
das Buch aufgestapelt und am Ende waren
wir richtig eingespieltes Team
[Musik]
zwischendurch ist dann erstmal die
Kamera abgeschmiert weil es alles viel
zu lang gedauert hat aber wir haben es
tatsächlich geschafft und am nächsten
Tag stand dann der erste kleine Umzug
auf den Hof an ich muss heute noch
meinen Keller ausräumen das ist der
erste Akt für den Umzug und der ist so
vollgestopft
ich habe letztens als die sie so zu Ende
ging einfach alles hier reingestellt
ohne irgendeine Ordnung oder irgendein
Konzept und genau so sieht's jetzt auch
aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es geht doch viel schneller als gedacht
manchmal stellt man sich eine Aufgabe so
unglaublich riesengroß vor und dann
fängt man einmal an und merkt dass man
sich gar nicht so lange davor hatte
drücken müssen und wisst ihr was das
Beste ist diesen einen kleinen ersten
Schritt zu gehen und den Keller
umzuziehen hat so viel in mir gelöst
dass ich mich auf einmal wieder richtig
auf den Umzug freue und vor allem auch
auf die ganzen Veränderungen die dieser
Umzug mit sich bringt
[Musik]
und nach langem hin und her habe ich
mich jetzt dazu entschieden dass ich den
alten Garten einfach noch bis ungefähr
Oktober diesen Jahres behalte so dass
der Abschied ein bisschen fließender ist
wir haben juli einziehen und ich dann
den alten Garten immer noch habe und da
immer noch hingehen kann und dann ähm
fange ich im neuen Garten an zu gärtnern
und lass den alten gehen
[Musik]